in a world full of zoom calls when
people can only see our
top half winnie the pooh style how can
we still be glamorous while sitting at
home on our couches or
working from home well our next guest
has that answer
he has designed some of the most iconic
gowns
ever and he's one of my favorite people
let alone mentors on project runway
please welcome christian siriano
gone you look divine i do you think so
divine um okay
so how did the quarantine
affect you because when people could not
get their hands on masks there you were
at your atelier yeah making it with
everyone and
cuomo deemed your business an essential
business so that you could make ppe and
open i tweeted him i begged him i was
like we want to help
so i was trying to keep my kind of small
business in new york but then also like
do something great so it all worked out
for everybody
um i will say masks are quite a
challenge but we've done yeah we've
donated almost
a million well everything we're doing i
admire i applaud and i already love you
but that just
put you into superhero stratosphere now
can we do a little quarantine fashion
show
yeah what should we do should we bring
out jennifer now let's bring first look
come on
this is all about this is like no fear
have fun kind of like sexy pajamas on
bottom and then like some glamour on the
top
it's a little called the jones on the
bottom samantha jones on the bottom
but it's giving me betsy johnson vibes
on the top
old school like like you know i love a
dangle earring i wish earrings were all
at the shoulder i think that's just like
a hit
and you know headbands you know i don't
always love them but i think for a zoom
call why not
i have to say i think you look
absolutely beautiful jennifer
really i mean hair and makeup a pink lip
why not a pink lip at 10 a.m
for your friends on zoom i know i was
hoping my friends were having a cocktail
at 9 a.m on premiere day i was like is
that weird
um so a hundred percent but you're right
accessories
make such a huge difference now why did
you need an outfit jennifer
well so many people nowadays are working
at home and they're doing
you know trainings and meetings with
their bosses and clients online
so you still have to look good at least
from the waist up because you can't be
going on with your employer with
buttoning your hair and sweatpants on i
gotta tell you you look like you're
straight off holiday thank you jennifer
seriously you look gorgeous okay peyton
will you please come on
out okay i love this look hey are those
my shoes
they probably are i'm not kidding i wore
those to work today i'm pretty sure
by the way i was so obsessed with the
bottom because of course i'm like oh
moccasins with like a faux
that is not the look we're not looking
at that i know
and of course that's what i'm
gravitating towards but now my
eye is raised and you are all class
now why did you need an outfit well i'm
violently single drew
um so i'm using this for speed dating
online through zoom
the guys at home are really struggling i
feel you and
the thing is i think it's more of a
conversation here we have plaids and
i don't know gingham and the whole look
it's the vest well
i have to say i do miss the era of
bowler hats and yeah you know jackets
and
a little bit of it a more etiquette
style
to our fashion dress to impress so i
think that you look fantastic
be date away great therese will you
please come out here
oh my god again
christian why am i going straight no
that is not how you want to live your
life but it but look
look how comfortable but how glamorous
on top volume and texture
hoops i love it all christian you have a
tip like don't wear
like soft fabrics and maybe go for a
little more tailored on a zoom look
i just think because you're in this
small screen it's like you don't want
too much
it's like much is about like where's the
texture where's the glamour
if it's chiffon and wrinkly it's not
working i have to say
i am so inspired because i get to dress
up at work i'm even
extra lazy in my real life i'm always in
like
a really threadbare old vintage cotton
t-shirt so now that i'm gonna step up my
home game
now teresa why did you need an outfit
well
i'm wearing this for a good friend's
birthday party so we're sharing recipes
cocktails and the best part is i don't
have to wear heels or
drive and is it at night or is it at
night
uh-huh okay i think that changes the
game because yeah this is an
evening look oh gorgeous love being in
your world
in your clothes i'm in your world
finally because i've been living in your
world and i want to do so many things
with you
christian you guys thank you so much
jennifer
peyton therese thank you to our
beautiful quarantine fashion models you
are bringing it
and christian i love you
love you